[Music]
dr. sleep so dr. sleep is the sequel to
The Shining written and directed by Mike
Flanagan it starts Ewan McGregor Ewan
McGregor plays Dan as in Danny as in doc
as in the little kid riding his tricycle
through the hallways and the shining
guess he's him he's all grown up now now
there's another little girl she has
shine too and there's this cult out
there who feeds off of the life force
the energy the shine of people who have
that shining so bring on Stephen King
horror sequel also Stanley Kubrick when
you're watching it it does fundamentally
come across as a Stephen King story does
it come across as a Stanley Kubrick
story this movie does have Stanley
Kubrick ism's to remind you that yeah
this is the sequel to a Stanley Kubrick
movie which is funny because it's famous
if not a little infamous a Stephen King
did not like Stanley Kubrick's
adaptation of The Shining which I
imagine made this a very difficult task
to take on adapt this Stephen King book
which is also a sequel to a Stanley
Kubrick movie that King wasn't really a
huge fan of which is also a sequel to a
Stanley Kubrick movie you're making a
Stanley Kubrick's sequel sequel to a
movie
there's Stanley Kubrick fans and a lot
of film fans consider a modern horror
classic good luck
but hey think of it this way at least
you're not making a Star Wars movie
because that's where the drama truly
lies what a time it's a weird time it's
more Stephen King than Stanley Kubrick
but does have Kubrick isms in it to
remind you yes this is still part of
that world
that universe and it works you and
McGregor was great in this movie you
could tell he has a lot of damage from
his childhood trauma he still carries it
with him here he's like I keep your head
down don't let anyone know you have this
shine because other forces can hear you
the same character Arcas Rambo or Jason
Bourne or a lot of spy movies out there
that were just like right we're gonna
lay low up can't anymore Rebecca
Ferguson it's perfection I mean that in
every way possible I just kind of took
to calling Europe evils at 10 and 15
which is funny because her and her cult
her crew they're the villains is a very
villainous they feed off of people and
caused a lot of pain and horror and fear
and that's kind of what they do but this
movie does a good job of giving you you
know their side of things is we see that
so much in horror movies out there it's
like all the creepy thing it's either
the cream
good thing under the batter in your
closets mentally racking your brain
glowing eyes in the dark oh it's all
scary and their faceless nameless scary
things that are there to scare people
because they're just evil right this
movies like yeah but what's their side
of it well they're scared too they just
don't want to die I need to feed off of
your life force you know it's
complicated I do you have to watch the
shining if you're gonna watch this movie
can you go into this movie being like
I've never seen this shining for the
thrills on the supernatural horror
element with this cult coming after
people coming after kids it works fine
on its own but when it starts to bring
in the shining into it you're not gonna
be lost cuz you're gonna get what it's
saying it's just not gonna mean much to
you you're gonna be like I get it
why do I care why do I give a [ __ ] so I
do suggest having watched The Shining
before you watch dr. sleep or you know
what have a refresher I watched The
Shining last night before I watched dr.
sleep today having watched The Shining
and dr. sleep within a day of each other
they're both about two and a half hours
long in run time it's me a five hour
supernatural epic that really does work
well in tandem with each other
so dr. sleep stands on its own in its
horror element but also serves as a
proper sequel to Stanley Kubrick's
Shining I felt that delve deeper into
the lore of the shining it actually has
its own message about how we live in a
less spiritual world these days and what
that means for that universe I had a
great time with it or if less spiritual
world isn't the right phrase right here
how to rephrase it we live in a more
technological and Kippur OH mindset as
opposed to the spiritual mindset of old
yeah there it is I'll say dr. sleeve was
definitely worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray right so dr. sleep
have you seen it what do you think about
it or what about The Shining have you
seen The Shining what do you think of
the shiny whatever you think of either
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]